nothing not to love we just thought we
saw a brown recluse spider
uh outside of my home get the photo up
that i posted and it's not a brown
recluse it is a southern
house spider but we didn't know
we didn't know common mistake common
mistake and of course you put something
like that up on twitter and uh
you know i don't know why when i do
something like that i think i'm gonna
get like an entomologist
who's like actually it's just people
responding you're a fat recluse
and i'm like that's not particularly
helpful in this situation
but it is a male coup
it is a southern house spider
thank you someone in a facebook spider
group with emotional problems
just just classifying spiders anytime
day or night
just a happy person
a lot of people you know they're all
these brown recluse spiders are all over
austin texas
and it is a big you know thing there was
actually a big
lawsuit because a guy a caretaker at an
airbnb
was bit by a brown recluse spent 75 days
in a hospital
uh spent 600 000 on medical expenses
it wound all the way up uh the case went
to the texas supreme
court and then eventually they sided
with the
homeowner let's take a listen this is
the news
okay let's take a listen it's a spider
bite lawsuit
why am i leaving here i don't know it's
the lawsuit about the spider bite
that went to the supreme court
spider bite in the hill country has
turned into a lengthy legal battle
between two men
look at this guy can we get out of here
please keep
look at this i mean this guy
he likes spiders to bite him he can only
come if spiders are biting him
he has a hooker take a brown recluse and
and it bites him
and that's how he can come all right
anyway continue this i'm sure he's a
lovely man
the supreme court kxan's alex capriello
shows us why this case has been so hard
for the courts to resolve
and we want to warn you some of the
images you are about to see
may be considered graphic it was a cold
day in december
65 year old henry mccall a caretaker at
an airbnb property
reached under the single please start
this is like they're shooting it
to be like like very dramatic
he's like some of the images are
disturbing because they're of poor
people
now some i want to give you fair warning
some of the images are disturbing
because they are of people who clean
houses
for a living he considered graphic
it was a cold day in december 65 year
old henry mccall a caretaker at an
airbnb property in fredericksburg
reached out to fix it
it was a cold day in december uh a 97
year old caretaker like the guy's 65
he's a caretaker i feel horrible what
does that even mean
caretaker of an airbnb by the way that's
like a term that's used
that was like jack torrance in the
shining
he's a caretaker of an airbnb
the guy's 65 years old and he's just i
think attacked by brown recluses but
the prick on his arm
the highly poisonous spider caused
mccall's arm to bruise and swell
he spent 75 days in the hospital
underwent six
surgeries and spent nearly six hundred
thousand dollars on hospital bills
but for the grace of god you know
i'm still here and i'm grateful he goes
and i'm not he blames the property
owner homer hillis for his suffering
saying he should be liable
since he didn't warn him of the possible
danger in his bnb
attorneys tell us he normally wouldn't
be since those animals are native to the
land
similar legal cases regarding indigenous
animal biting and attacking people have
all taken place
outdoors so now the texas supreme court
judges will hear both sides
on whether or not a landowner has a duty
to protect the people on their property
if that fight happens indoors mccall
claims hillis knew about the infestation
mccall says he saw a full-size mattress
and frame at the home crawling with
spiders but hillary's claims he had an
exterminator come and take care of the
property several times
he also mentions his stellar online
reviews which never mention an insect
problem hillis also points out
any judgment that makes him laugh by the
way for anyone who operates that looks
like a prison
that's true the property in the hill
take a look at that that's an airbnb
that looks like a like a youth detention
facility
that's an airbnb that can't be it who
and god's
that's it who in god's name
is paying money to stay in that airbnb
by the side of the highway with this
poor elderly caretaker
i mean and the texas supreme court tells
the guy to go [ __ ] himself
which i love yeah they go hey the
spiders were here before you sir
should we finish this yeah of course
hilus also points out
any judgment that makes him liable will
be detrimental for anyone who operates a
property in the hill country
hopefully they will bring about some
regulations to exterminate
for bed bugs for scorpions
for brown recluse spiders and black
wiggle spiders alex capriello kxan news
we reached out to the airbnb owner homer
hillis as well as his lawyer
they chose not to comment until the
texas supreme court makes their decision
homer judges will hear both arguments
the airbnb owner
homer hillis my name is homer hillis
i run an airbnb and there are some
spiders in there but they're native to
the land
and my caretaker who's 115 years old
ended up getting bit and he had to spend
75 days
and by the way can you like look at that
that is not what should be done at like
a hospital that
that stitching looks like it was done by
a
child what
thank i pray i don't need any medical
attention in this state ever i pray to
god
i don't need to go to a hospital here
look at that it looks like a witch
did it my name is homer helis
i run a youth detention center that i
also use as an
airbnb and there's there's black widows
and brown recluses in every room
and my caretaker was near killed
and he sued me homer us
god